there I am oh my goodness I was talking
for a while and then I was blacked out
and who knew what was going on we are
standing by for Donald Trump at a corona
rally in Phoenix Arizona coronavirus
loves this rally as you can see we right
now are listening well we're not going
to listen to Charlie Cork and oh boy my
phone is going off because people are
going crazy let's see here okay and as
you can see here Arizona case numbers
are quite high very very high and that
is where this rally is currently taking
place so you know the logic of that we
don't know people wondering why we can't
hear anything it's cuz it's muted I just
don't think we really need to hear this
stuff until Donald Trump comes out which
is now which is right now so we're going
to we're gonna get to this this is a
disastrous idea as all of you can
imagine we'll keep the audio down just
for copyright purposes and as this goes
on feel free to send in your super chats
and questions and twitch twitch comic
comments and questions we will get to
them after Trump already sweaty before
it has even started and I expect that we
will see a lot more of that this is a
very very very bad idea my friends but
it is happening let's see what's going
out the music I want to keep down
because of copyright from oh boy it's
still happening yeah so I don't know how
long Trump is expected to speak he's
running about 10 minutes early scheduled
originally for 6:40 p.m. Eastern Time
were about 10 minutes shy of that and we
will what do we know what do we know we
let's see what we hear about testing
let's see what we hear about all sorts
of different things visibly sweaty Trump
prepared to deliver unhinged remarks in
Arizona see what's happening the music
is still playing man this isn't this the
worst isn't this the worst of Trump
today by the way when asked were you
kidding when you said you tried to
reduce coronavirus testing because the
White House is saying you're kidding
Trump said I know
kid I'm never kidding so that that was
not good not good
arguably criminal certainly murderous
and is the music still playing yeah okay
thanks to Matt Chavez who says I have I
hate Trump is a few miles away from me
again a Jake says have you ever
considered going on the damage report or
having John on the show would be glad to
do either Andrew Moore says expecting a
red sweaty and unhinged event today what
is what why won't oh look it looks like
there's a fight now immediately there's
a fight or no it's just I guess that's
just how regular Trump teenagers behave
that's not considered a fight that's
normal
[Music]
thanks to and rock for the twitch Prime
subscription how long is this precursor
going to be this is nuts I might play
some of my cameos later I've been having
a good time doing cameos alright it
looks like we're getting out to get
started
[Music]
it sounds like there's booming and then
people chanting USA over it but it
sounds like there's a big booing
contingent here thank you also Li clean
wood thank you to Lee Greenwood but I'm
thrilled to be in Arizona with thousands
of patriotic young Americans matriod up
tall for America and refused to kneel to
the radical level oh he seems high yeah
[Applause]
there is something going on you feel it
right yeah he's hopped up you know the
other night a speech I made on Saturday
night in a very good place and we had a
great evening and the ratings came out
the ratings on television it was the
number one remember they expected a
million people and 6200 showed up that's
the story they expected a million people
6200 showed up for them it's all about
the ratings no for you it's all about
the folks back there CNN MS DNC
[Music]
though they're very happy to see that
Fox had the number-one show this is the
number one show in the history of Fox
News that's pretty good 100 a night let
us also show our appreciation to my good
friend Charlie I said Charlie is
something so for some reason I have
Charlie Kurt's phone number in my phone
mobilizing a new generation of
pro-american student activists which
triggered really smart and you'll be up
here someday somebody they're not booing
they're saying boo urns be up here right
here who are tough and smart and
determined and truly unstoppable you are
I want to thank also Kimberly and I want
to thank my son boy I watched my son I
got here Wow I said what's this all
about Trump doesn't know how to actually
seem to like his kids because he doesn't
it's funny to everyone here today and
watching live all across our country
thank you for bravely defending our
nation our values and our great American
Hero
[Music]
thanks Brian through the members if I
see that I know what's going on because
you're on the front lines of a
tremendous intellectual struggle lecture
of our country intellectual that's the
word I do the future of our country you
see what's happening to disgrace it's a
disgrace if we weren't here you could
forget it okay but we're gonna be such
intellectuals like charlie kirk going
for a long time
November 3rd is a big day get out get
the parents get the friends get the
husband get the wait get everybody right
now the difference is they get everybody
even if they're not registered if
they're not citizens here's this voter
fraud routine if they're here illegally
they get everybody give me some examples
of non-citizens voting base and you know
you go through a whole nation and you
see what's going on and they report zero
in legality check out California
sometime
okay check out now check out the the
deal that they signed with judicial was
it was I think Judicial Watch was like
one minute you know 1.5 million people
they settled they agreed that that many
people nobody knows what really
shouldn't have been voting a lot of
things they settled and I'm really and
Judicial Watch said look we were so high
what difference did it make what
difference that are big no will they
play a very dirty game you're fighting
against an oppressive left-wing ideology
that is driven by hate and seeks to
purge all dissent and you understand
that amazing at that age right your
young people generally a couple of old
stirs out their friends among the
radical left demands absolute conformity
from every professor researcher reporter
journalist corporation entertainer this
sounds like a Stephen Miller line pissed
speaker and private citizen but we have
Charlie and we have our people and our
people is strong
our people are stronger and our people
are slaughtered and we are the elite we
are there you know is he against the
elite or he wants to have the elite on
his side I'm confused
well you know the elite I said what are
you talking about the elite who's the
only Daniel E right they're not the
elite you dearly okay you smarter you're
better-looking
he seems looks at her future you know
your way around better believe it or not
there's only one thing they have they're
more vicious
they are vengeance they are vicious
people anyone who descents from their
orthodoxy must be punished cancelled or
banished that includes from television
you say it but you will not be to see a
lot of people in the chat unable to tell
whether this is on script or off script
this is a disastrous on script reading I
didn't like the tone and I said you know
it's really nice now he's off I'm here
and you're not
[Music]
we overlook later he'll drink water and
show us he knows how to use a spoon
you're the courageous warriors standing
in the way of what they want to do and
their goals and standing up for faith
and family God country and freedom right
um let's freedom do und
USA USA
there it is you knew you could disappear
that's funny
unbelievable spirit I appreciate it
thank you very much
but the radical left they hate our
history they hate our values and they
hate everything we prized as Americans
that we're right because our country
didn't grow great with them okay it grew
great with you and your thought process
and your ideology the left-wing mob is
trying to demolish your heritage so they
could replace it with a new repressive
regime that they alone control in all
seriousness I think it's really
important that Trump has nothing to run
on all he's doing is just attacking the
left putting up straw men and taking
them down and even struggling to do it
there's no message here I'd be curious
whether he even mentions one policy
today
tyrants and people that don't love our
country they don't love our country the
left is not trying to promote justice or
equality lift up the downtrodden they
have one goal the pursuit of their own
political power for whatever reason but
that's their goal that really seems to
be their goal their goal of their
sickness and if you give power to people
that demolish monuments and attack
churches and seize city streets and set
fire to buildings they don't have power
no one said nothing is sacred thanks a
lot for the membership we stopped them
last night you see that Andrew Jackson
vote Trump someone completely unrelated
to anything he does in law enforcement
prevented a statue from being destroyed
[Music]
the problem we have is States they're
weak they're weak the many of the
governor's many of the mayors you see
what's going on and it's by the way just
so you understand it's all Liberal
Democrat states could you imagine if
sleepy Joe ever became president yeah
the state's doing the best on
coronavirus are overwhelmingly blue
states New England's doing the best 22
of the worst 24 states or red states the
guy's delirious
he would have nothing to do with it a
lot come in the Oval Office let's just
do what we want to do that's why and you
know today he's with Obama President
Obama it only took them how long a year
and a half to endorsement what did it
take a year and a half to endorse him
even after he won he didn't endorse him
for a long time that's totally untrue
very shortly after Biden actually
secured the delegates needed Barack
Obama endorsed him not that it matters
but just it's all lies he wanted a win
but Joe Joe won but if you remember in
my campaign he fought harder than
crooked Hillary President Obama fought
me harder he said you cannot let him win
you cannot destroy he was all over the
place I said this guy's spending all of
his time can't believe who won that's
right I thought Hillary won by three
million and don't forget
don't forget I'm only here because of
him and Biden I'm only here because we
know the reaction from race because look
what he did a good job we wouldn't have
been here there would have been no
reason so I'm only here because of
President Obama and the job he did and
sleepy Joe Biden and the job that he
didn't do other than he did a good job
for his son good job mentions a billion
dollars but I wouldn't be you to buy
Korean happy the fake news doesn't
reported they were very unhappy there
was tremendous dissent tremendous anger
a lot of people in this audience I can
tell you but we're here today to declare
that we will never cave to the left wing
and the left wing intolerance okay
talk about fighting an invisible enemy
surrender to mob violence and we will
uphold American freedom equality and
justice for every citizen of every
background very strong powerful that's
who we are that is what we believe and
that is why we must prevail on November
3rd we have to prevail get out there I
don't know that this type of story with
absolutely no real case for reelection
will get him back from 10 points down I
just don't know I a great gentleman a
great governor of this state he won by a
lot of votes and I said to a governor
how am i doing he said you're doing
really well and I said good because he
knows better than anybody he really has
done a tremendous job as governor
Arizona Governor Doug Ducey where is
Doug
thank you dumb
and somebody who we need to keep in the
Senate a woman who works very hard I
just got back from if she's nothing you
like the border wall martha mcsalley
martha you see this right there's
mcsalley let's see how she's doing
thank you mom thank you mom Wow
ugly ugly ugly thank you gonna get rough
we gotta get her in and Mark Kelly who
she's running against is an oppression
week on China and lots of other things
China if between Biden and Kelly and
these people they get in China will own
this country and they don't Kelly's
getting in we have done great before the
plague set in before the plague came
over right it came over we were doing
the greatest we're the greatest economy
we have the greatest job numbers we have
a greatest of everything there wasn't a
thing where we weren't number one we
soon that will be a year ago like he'll
be running on a year ago things were
really great cuz they had in sixty-seven
years and we were doing great and then
they said there's a plague coming over
from China here it comes what a disgrace
what a disgrace and now you saw last
week the jobs numbers the biggest ever
you saw the retail sales go check out my
clip you are about to get hit with
garbage math I predicted that they would
start saying we're having the fastest
job growth in history I explained that
in a clip okay we're gonna have a good
third quarter and right when those
numbers are announced you have your
election so that's hopefully a sign from
up there but I think we're gonna die on
the spot and they are trying to do their
best to keep the country shut down and
close because they love those numbers
not get me good but there's not a lot
they're gonna be able to do about it
not a lot blue states safely reopening
indoor dining reopening here in
Massachusetts it's a complete and total
farce thank you for being here I want to
thank you for being such a great
thank you and we also have some of your
warriors great representatives and they
fought with me on the impeachment hooks
right the great hoaxes are based on a
telephone conversation that was perfect
the only one that got impeached in
history hopefully will be the only one
they got impeached over a perfect
telephone call like perfect it was just
a perfect hall perfect this was like the
perfect call I said wait a minute
I said we don't need lawyers just keep
reading thank goodness we had it trimmed
it was very good that we had it cuz
remember Adams is he having having a
medical event right now he made up a
phony stand that's what they're all
about I said it before they're vicious
Paul Gosar stand up Paul where's Paul
Paul thanks season for the member for
number three great God is a man I spoke
to him this morning Andy Biggs he
believed break
Thank You Annie Freedom golfers
now that vark Meadows is our great chief
he's our chief ooh
mark meadows by the way anybody think
the crowd knows who these people are
mark Mathers but Andy took over and the
freedom caucus is doing great thank you
thank you and freedom caucus somebody
got to know very well during the hugs
Debbie let's go if you want proof that
they don't even know what they're
cheering for on Saturday and Tulsa Trump
said people should go to prison for a
year for burning a flag and the crowd
went absolutely crazy they're supposed
constitutional conservatives they
cheered for a year in prison for burning
the flag which is constitutionally
protected they don't know what they're
cheering for I don't know how they found
their way in there another warrior David
Schweikert
David thank you thank you David thank
you and a man who is very understated he
just gets it done behind the scenes
never likes to go on television never
likes talking a lot but he's a great
congressman
right from one of my favorite states
Florida Matt Gaetz
and say your picture of Matt Matt gasps
that's relevant
he keeps it low-key and simple right no
actually he keeps it up and not simple
but he's great and he does a fantastic
job thank you man this is you try along
with a lot of great people Arizona
Treasurer Kimberly Yee big thanks to
this guy really thank you House Speaker
rusty Bowers rusty rusty Thank You rusty
thanks
Senate President wow that's a big deal
Karen Fann how much time will be spent
just naming like if he's just gonna name
people I'll thank supporters I
appreciate my supporters much more than
whoever Trump is thanking don't okay
she says yes she knows she knows and
Navajo Nation vice president
Myron lousier thank you touching doing
that I also want to recognize a truly
courageous woman angel mom he's a friend
of mine too by the way
well great first let me say thanks to
Jeremy who just grabbed the membership
on my website you're a much better
person than anybody Trump's naming you
remember number four illegal immigration
nobody will ever go through hopefully
nobody ever has to go through
unfortunately people will have to do it
but she is one of the first people I met
and she lost a magnificent child to an
illegal immigrant and it's just a
horrible thing and she's spent her life
she's spent the last long period of
years fighting and fighting and dividing
my people have gotten to respect her
greatly Mary and Mendoza well being
[Applause]
that's it
political traffic boys lot of guts he's
got a lot of guns policies would not
actually deal with the issue he's
referring to and thank you a very
special thank you to pastor Luke Barnett
and the dream city church for hosting us
where is the pastor pastors at the
pastor
thanks to Brian good-looking new member
number five well I want to see this guy
oh he's good I'll be here I'll get here
son
when will Trump get to the policy
proposals right thank you thank you
great job pass right here I hear great
things thank you very much we're also
joined by a band who became such a
superstar overnight you know I put him
there as a little bit of a filler to be
honest no job he was the ambassador to
Germany right and he was like you know I
needed somebody to sit warm out a chair
he wore out the jaded warm it he wore it
out right Matt Gaetz he wore out the
chair Richard Grinnell
what is this like is this
well in 2016 Trump would just read polls
during his rallies now he just names
people are fantastic I want a picture of
him walking into the DOJ with a big sad
show and I realize what he's walking and
those came and he had lots of gold gold
in those satchels did they have imagine
watching this and being like I shouldn't
vote for this guy do what happens but we
caught him right in many countries whose
health care systems work if you saw
someone talking like this in public
they'd be referred for a free mental
health evaluate our hold potentially
here it's cheered as a presidential
rally Jeff Jeff thanks Gabe you saw it
could have fun everyone in this room is
bound together by a shared set of moral
principles and enduring truths which are
believed the United States of America is
the greatest and most righteous nation
that has ever existed
gonna keep it that way we believe that
every citizen has the fundamental right
to think to speak to live and pray
according to their own conscience we
believe that the beloved heroes of
American history should not be torn down
by militant mobs but held up as an
example it's weird that Trump is all
about he wants to be with the winners
and yet he's obsessed with keeping the
statues of losers of the Civil War up
right isn't that a little bit of a
conflict we stopped him they were
heading toward the Jefferson Memorial
they have they couldn't care less I
think half of them don't even know who
Thomas Jefferson is
how about ulysses s grant Ulysses wants
the Confederate soldiers but you only
yes but he's the one that defeated the
Confederate soldiers so what's that all
about how about Gandhi how about
Churchill you know Churchill because
this is going outside of our country now
no we'll stop it don't worry this isn't
Giga Chad behavior right Giga chats good
and this is it can somebody clarify on
Twitter please
so our heroes are not a source of shame
they are an example and something that
you can all look up to a true example of
greatness a point of pride and we will
honor them and cherish them forever we
will cherish them and we have to cherish
our past we have to cherish good or bad
we have to understand our past we have
to understand our history because if we
don't know our history it could all
happen again Trump a student of history
[Applause]
[Music]
it's happening today that's the problem
we believe in law and order we support
the men and women of law enforcement and
we stand with the citizens in every city
and every community and every part of
our country who wish to live in safety
security dignity and peace okay
and we know that American patriots don't
bow down to foreign powers we don't back
that he literally asked China for help
guys and the only authority we worship
is our God
pandering is unbecoming of him these are
the values our country was built upon
these are the values that unite our
citizens and these are the values that
powered our civilization to its towering
heights is he doing the wind down
already without even having done any
policy discussion reaching new summits
of scientific endeavor artistic triumph
and human achievement guided by these
timeless convictions my administration
has been delivering historic gains for
the American people right
[Applause]
like no one has ever done in the first
three and a half years of a presidency
did I miss his plan to repeal repeal and
replace Obamacare as he had not has he
not gotten to that yet we will have
close to 300 federal judges appointed in
a prayer that's why he's got to go
I need someone else good step if you get
10 at salon 300 an all-time record and
very importantly we confirm two great
Supreme Court justices yeah it's a
reminder of why he's got to go and we
have to win because obviously we need
more justices on the Supreme Court
that's how important that we do realize
I've always heard it's the most
important thing you can do
I always said defense but that's right
there
Supreme Court justices and judges and we
are setting records I guess this is his
policy proposal undocumented immigrants
are bad and he's gonna keep appointing
lunatic judges okay bad policy and I
very proudly created the sixth branch of
the United States Armed Forces ace for
base force there it is people don't even
know
next everybody give us a home that's a
figure you think you're just that if you
did just that that's like that's a good
presidency think of that that's one of
many many things we'll go over a few of
them but many many things so the Air
Force was the last one there was 74 he
say space farts at one point that he
misspeak or did I did I miss here
another branch we're gonna have a
general a nice general we have right now
on the Joint Chiefs of Staff a full full
deal and that's a great honor because
space is going to be very important
first they smiled when I came up with
the idea I never talked about it on the
campaign right I don't think I ever
mentioned it once
it just didn't hurt and I learned as I
was going through military and really an
amazing thing space is going to be soon
the more that one of our most important
of all and it's an honor we're now doing
a Hydra sonic I called super duper z'
missile goes 17 times faster than the
fastest missile right yeah that's not
true we've already gone through the math
of that and debunk that it's not so no
nobody told him I guess imagine cheering
that the missile 17 times faster by the
way it's a big deal and VA
accountability a big deal they've been
trying for 50 years almost 50 years on
both accountability they couldn't fire
people that treated our events badly
down we can say you're fired
oh by the way you had a big deal that's
right that's right you had a big deal in
Arizona I've been reading about it for
years now I hope that there's a stream
after this that will interview people
coming out and will say which of his
ideas did you like the best
like which idea really made it so you
were like I've got a vote for him that
would be a great thing to do so between
the unions and civil service and all of
the things they couldn't fire him but we
made it so that you can now say you're
fired get out
and they'll give our veterans the care
they so richly deserve you know choice
is so big instead of waiting for a week
two weeks five weeks you have no idea
how bad it was right if they have to
wait and they have great doctors we have
great doctors and remember that veterans
choice which he's now taking credit for
isn't Obama policy signed into law I
believe in 2014 so if he can't get rid
of it he'll take credit for it even
though Obama did it it's cheap we save
money most simplement we save lives
people would get online and they're okay
Obama well by the time they see a doctor
in some cases they charge terminally
they they are terminally ill it would
take weeks and weeks and now we have VHS
that's why you see good store is 91
percent approval rating funny thing as
an tragic thing is there's horror
stories like that in the for-profit
health care system which Trump has done
nothing to deal with but he's horrified
about the ones he can claim to have
fixed which actually Obama fixed he
passed the largest package of tax cuts
and tax reforms and we passed the
largest number of regulation cuts by a
factor of many times that's the
meaningless administration even though
in some cases eight years and in one
case more nobody has cut regulation like
we've got regulation not even close
why and it's one of the reasons we did
so well though imagine being a student
for Trump and hearing him say hey we cut
a bunch of regulations being like girl
that's great Obama cares unfair
individual mandate
which punish young Americans like you
for the privilege of not buying bad
health insurance that's really what it
was bad get the privilege of not buying
and you had to pay for it not too good
so we got rid of it that was a big deal
that was one of the most unpopular
things anywhere on any subject we will
always protect people with pre-existing
conditions and you have Martha's pledge
that she is going to do that also so
we're gonna do that so the Democrats
can't make that pledge because they're
gonna raise your taxes like crazy I
never heard you know all my life
I think Doug can maybe explain it but
Doug all my life I'd watch and the best
politicians who want to cut taxes not
raise taxes all of a sudden we're in an
age where things are very different
let's face it ripping down statues one
of the things as the Democrats want to
raise your taxes to a level that nobody
can even believe that's not true and it
won't be nearly enough to pay for what
they want to do you talk about bad
health care i I actually am hopeful that
most people don't fall for these really
stupid talking points anymore
thought it was supposed to be the other
way right I mean clearly some people do
but on November 3rd I don't think
they're gonna do to you
we passed right to try to give
critically ill patients access to
life-saving cures so they don't have to
travel all around the world and see if
they can find and we've had tremendous
success with that right to try very
proud of it they've been trying to get
that one done for 40 years you guys
noticed this elbow thing pump does all
the time and I've just come from the
Arizona border Yuma where we marked the
completion of over 220 miles of
brand-new beautiful border wall
[Applause]
okay you know you don't hear about the
what they don't want to talk about the
wallet I'm with university Diaw to then
you're not ever has the Democrat Party
fought so hard against something and do
you notice they never talk about the
wall cuz in the end I gave it up they
give up we won we're building it fully
funded completely I could build numerous
walls with all the money I remember that
the promise was by the end of his first
term a full wall across the us-mexico
border this is he's claiming victory but
this was a failed another failed promise
it's flying around
we're gonna watch everyone pour into our
country the drug remember they said the
walls obsolete and I said today nobody
heard it I didn't thought it was sort of
I think I said it but I'm sure people
have said it over the years you know
you're in an industry in many cases you
have a computer in about two weeks it's
old sometimes you have community but
that's true in technology I said to some
of the people I meet them all I say the
problem with your business it gets
obsolete quick to things that will never
be obsolete a wheel and a wall right oh
yeah
and they'd say that wall is obsolete
with modern technology no no mana
technologies like let's watch everybody
pour it now we have a wall so we've
built 220 miles we're going to have
minus 2,000 by January every single
element I met with Border Patrol who a
fantastic by the way
every single element they wanted you
have to see through Ellen makes sense
you have to do all of the different we
have cameras on it we have sensors on it
it is just a 30 feet high it's very hard
very hard
we have anti-climb provision on the top
we have a whole deal wall and it's very
powerful and by the way where that wall
is nobody's getting through nobody
we put a chunk California off the record
California would say please can we have
the walk this is California you know if
they didn't want the wall they don't
want the wall but they wanted the wall
right because right next to San Diego's
a wonderful town in Mexico you know the
town I won't mention it but they're
heavily infected he genuinely seems to
be having a medical event right now said
the other night did anybody see my
speech the other night on Saturday night
no one were you drunk at what I said the
other night there's never been anything
where they have so many names I could
give you 19 or 20 names for that right
it's got all different names wuhan oh
god on was catching on is he gonna say
it again
coronavirus right will he say kung flu
yeah magic trick kungfu like kobe 19
covet I say what's the 19 covet 19 some
people can't explain what the 19 give me
this is racist and racist that's an odd
name I could give you a many many names
some people call it the Chinese flu the
China flu right they call it the China
as opposed to check that China I've
never seen anything like it but here's
the story we are going to be stronger
than ever before and it's going to be
soon if we replace you 50 replace
and I think you'll remember you know now
Biden was going around like he's a tough
guy you know he doesn't know where the
hell he is weird where are you Joe Joe
where are you Joe so here's the dementia
routine but he's going around I stood up
for China no his son walked out with 1.5
billion to manage life and what he did
yesterday it was 1 billion now is 1.5
but they came out with this t-shirt and
some guy made a fortune where's hunt
where's that by the way where is hunter
[Music]
man he did well as vice president could
you imagine how Hunter's gonna do it
this guy ever won and the father sort of
like your kids right no idea what's
going on said Kaylee
where's Kate where's Kaylee where's
Kaylee
he must have pointed to some other
blonde woman in the crowd quick Joe this
is even more weaponized than I thought
actually I'm actually surprised oh is he
bringing Kaylee maggin Annie out imagine
Trump criticizing someone else for
nepotism I mean Sarah is gonna be the
governor of Arkansas pretty soon I hope
Sean's got his own show and this one
here she could run whatever else you
wanted but I said don't run don't run
just stay here we like the job you done
now we're doing great I stood up to
China like no other administration in
history for decades that I would
encourage you after this just find like
a speech of trumps from even four or
five years ago and the degree of
cognitive loss is actually stunning he
valued their currency and our you know
they like to say our people paid no no
our people didn't pay they devalued
their currency in order to pay it and
they also put money out there otherwise
they wouldn't have been able to sell
their product but what happened for many
years there is nobody ever
that ripped off the United States like
China nobody behind nobody I see us so
now we did a deal when you know the ink
wasn't dry when the when the plague flew
in huge look at the ink wasn't dry the
deal was great everybody was happy I was
thrilled two hundred and fifty billion
dollars worth of purchases over a short
period of time all great but the ink
wasn't dry and we got hit by the plague
so I'm not too happy about that
yeah but the long slow surrender is over
because today and every day we are
putting now America first America comes
first who goes with that again we
sparked a revolution in domestic energy
production in the United States is now
the number one producer of oil and that
imagine not being well on our way to
switching over to renewable energy how
embarrassing
America as of a couple of years ago is
no longer energy dependent we are now
energy dominant
and because our energy used went down so
much during this pandemic it was a very
very bad period of time because we have
yeah hidden me it was horrible we were
dramatically reduced in our polluting it
was just so bad but paying very little
for gasoline that's like the perfect
thing right that's the perfect thick oil
was too cheap we weren't polluting
enough we got to get back to the way it
was criminal justice reform which nobody
was able to get done very important very
important I secured record and permanent
funding for historically black colleges
and universities nobody knows John Smith
so there we created opportunities owns
along with Tim Scott and since then
countless jobs and 100 billion dollars
of new investment have poured into 9,000
of our most distressed neighborhoods in
the country nine thousand opportunities
run so think of it I did criminal
justice reform he did a lot of work on
prison or prison reform we did
Opportunity Zones think of this think of
all we've done and we've taken care of
the black colleges and universities and
this is apparently not a deep fake I
guess this is really the video from the
rally
our black communities know it and I
think you're gonna see something really
great happened because they understand
it they really understand it and I'll
tell you what whether it's any community
you talk about but if you take a look at
those numbers from pre virus but you
take a look at them in a year from now
you watch and you're a different
president I don't think you want to have
somebody else playing with them because
you're just about at a record high and
you put the wrong person in they will be
obliterated we know we know so we're
fighting for school choice because we
know that access to education is a civil
I hope everybody knows school choice is
code for make public schools fail by
taking money away and then saying look
they failed
let's take more money away and then say
look they failed even harder let's take
more money away that's what school
choice means
did you ever see two parties so
diametrically opposed to each other I
mean it's who can be opposed to that
but it's so important but the Democrats
will never ever allow that to happen
last month
we returned American astronauts to space
aboard American rocket he did nothing he
did nothing when it comes to that and we
knew he would try to take credit for it
to plant our beautiful American flag on
Planet gamma grant from South Africa
Elon Musk did that right and a way is
that is that a [ __ ] country or is
that an approved country according to
trump
and we destroyed we destroyed 100% of
the ISIS territorial Caliphate
completely untrue and the savage
terrorist monsters al-baghdadi and Kasim
Salome nee they are both dead percent
hundred percent of the Isis Caliphate
and when I took over the Caliphate was
gone like this it was a mess but weed
Caliphate went sideways no
administration has accomplished more in
just three and a half years it is I mean
I could go after those are just a few
points the stump no these are recorded
and a half just reading the points so if
you know that yet as you know in recent
months America is face down that unseen
enemy the virus from the distant land
that spread across the globe the sky
decorated our shores but invaded the
shores of us think of it
88 188 Nations I have a friend he's a
very smart guy said I didn't know there
were that many nations I said actually
go over 200 but 188 from killed
lieutenant salami and Admiral capicola
thank you and tomorrow the fake news
will be said he said he loves my buddy
he said he loves somebody terrible
[Applause]
okay
terrible I'll be a big trouble the
fakers imagine having a president they
are terrible people
poor the tubu the people that stood up I
just wanna set up place who said I love
you that's distance it whoa
did someone just lick this fit sit down
fast please dad don't let them see you
that's a lot of press back there look at
that okay is there even a crowd have we
seen the crowd or could this be a
cheering track it's done I never have a
speech where it's not like live
television
you know sometimes you'll have one where
you can actually speak and you have to
worry about like one little slip one
tiny little slip one word you could say
ten speeches one little word they'll say
he's lost it well when the one little
word is I tried to reduce testing yeah
that's gonna make headlines
in response we took swift and early
action to ban travel from China very
very early remember Nancy Pelosi and
that crazy group Nancy Pelosi she wanted
to dance in the street shot people in
the chat and press that I was drinking
water with only one hand Dinah from
coming here we saved tens of thousands
of lives with that early decision and
then we made an early decision on Europe
yet liberal lawmakers and Democrat
politicians condemned this policy the
Left rejected science in favor of their
fanatical devotion to open borders they
want open borders not just our southern
border this is why the left is so
dangerous yeah they always put their
ideology for some reason I envision that
if Trump tried to say the word of
vernacular he would have a lot of
trouble I'm not sure why the police
how's that a good idea
[Music]
[Applause]
you know I passed a set I was in the
White House and there was this set and
it had dem say think of it defund it
abolish I said what are they gonna do
fun
very few people support that and this is
the again I I think it's a mistake for
the left to push for abolish and defund
the police didn't nobody in the right
mind is gonna get rid of the police and
even the examples that people point to
did not really they reorganize the
police but remember very few people
actually support that
Phil no use imposing the other thanks -
yawns bell is remember 72 miles away a
lot of signups happen by the sign so in
addition to a show your series of
aggressive travel bans my administration
launched the greatest national
mobilization since World War two
we have done such a great job with this
between the ventilators and all of these
things including testing we're testing
so much we're now up to twenty seven
point five million tests I thought it
was 25 presents Eve like 25 million 27
they just told me twenty-seven point
five million tests now when you have all
those tests you have more cases right so
the news conversation they have more
cases well yeah slow it down and if
let's say other countries - 1 million 2
million big countries 3 million still
the soundest after me was a 3 million
tests so I don't know what they are now
but I know they're not anywhere near
where we are yeah so then they'll say
capita we have more cases now look we
want to do testing we want to do
everything but they use it to make us
look bad
but because of it our mortality rate is
so low it's so great what's happening so
this requires about 20 minutes of
discussion to understand what's going on
but needless to say Trump certainly
doesn't understand what's going on with
the mortality rate he says and they say
the cases have jumped instead of saying
what a job we're doing with testing but
we did the job with testing and we did
ventilators and we did we came up with
tests that nobody's we have so many
different types of tests with the 5
minute test the 10 minute test we have
tests you send him to a public lab but
privately we have tests it's a lot of
tests and other countries that have done
very well from got super high marks on
all of the tests job with that you've
done now the only ones I can't get to
say that are the fake news media
people they guess
[Applause]
someday it'll be recognized by history
someday but our actions and your
selfless sacrifice and that's what it
was saved hundreds of thousands of lives
we had to do it and we did the right
thing and I'll tell you what we did the
right thing
now we opened we got to get it open
because you know I said gotta get it
open people needed you know people get
sick from the other also it's not just
from the virus they get sick from all of
the other things that happen you know
what I mean we cut through red tape to
accelerate breakthrough therapies and
vaccines their vaccine very soon we
distributed 1.5 billion pieces of
personal protective equipment we
unleashed the medical and logistical
power of the United States military and
thanks to our efforts not a single
American who needed a ventilator has
been denied a ventilator I believe that
I'm fully committed God seems to be
employed remember when the New York
governor Governor Cuomo said he needs
40,000 ventilators so people said no no
you need 4,000 maybe 5,000 anyway we got
him what we thought was right they never
needed all of in fact they gave some to
other people but he didn't need 40
40,000 as opposed to 4,000 or 5,000 then
it worked out great that he wanted a
hospital built it's all worth a Javits
Convention Center we built it but he
didn't use it he could have used it for
the older people it was brand-new not
infected no infection then he wanted the
boat he wanted the boat to come up the
beautiful beautiful hospital ship you
know what that is called right and it
came up they could have used it for
senior citizens they didn't use it and
it's a shame that
shame it's a shame we're now the chief
ventilator producer anywhere in the
world we're helping other countries with
I'd love to know Emile is really hard to
make they're very complex they're baking
expensive and many countries are calling
us asking for help they need ventilators
and were able to do it because we're
making thousands of ventilators think of
the thousands of ventilators a week and
to rescue the US economy which is
happening now we pass over three
trillion dollars in relief measures we
suspended student loan payments and
interest for college students to protect
jobs for young Americans just like you
we took historic action to block the
entry of foreign workers into our nation
keep them out right brick hustling and
we believe that companies should hire
American workers and American students
first they have to have we gotta go
American we've got
you know we were down to three point
four three point five percent
unemployment and that's one thing yeah
but now we got to get it back to those
numbers then we can think right that
we're gonna get this guy taking people
in through merit only through merit or
mostly to a merit I better save mostly
because they'll say that's a terrible
thing you know you can't make a little
bit of a slip they'll say he said only
what about this what about that
generally speaking we like merit okay
okay we want American students to fill
American jobs that's the biggest
difference between us and the Left we
know that our first duty is to take care
of our citizens make America proclaim
and again
this Trump crescendo now
so before the play came in we had the
best of everything we had the best
interest rates we had the best
unemployment rates we had the best job
numbers ever we had everything
unemployment for african-americans
Hispanic Americans Asian Americans had
all reached the lowest rates ever
recorded in the history of our country
right so remember there's nothing
special like when unemployment is just
generally low it's usually low for every
group there's nothing special that Trump
did for any of those groups just just a
little fact-check diploma young people
without a college diploma we were number
one on every list you can think of women
75 years not as good I'm sorry but it
was getting ready to hit the all-time
women it was the best in 75 years so I
have to apologize could you believe that
right we did the best in 75 years and I
apologize to women but we were ready to
hit the all-time and then we got hit by
something that should have never
happened because they could have stopped
it young people had seen their wages
rise by more than ten percent they've
never seen anything like that okay these
these are mostly life we built this
strong it's hard to keep it like these
are mostly either lies or out of context
or deceptive statements in different
ways
quickly it's happening already we've
just added two and a half million jobs
last month think of that that's the
largest increase in the history of our
country yeah we just lost 45 million
though and just to add the topping as I
mentioned the 18% in retail sales the
surge was the biggest jump ever recorded
in this Shiva country the stock market
in the last 50 days is the best stock
market in history and what about the
last 90 though figure
go back a week fifty days the strongest
50 days in stock market history this is
Dori hopefully the end of the pandemic
and have you seen what we fight to
restore renew and rebuild our country
the heart left is trying to divide
denigrate and destroy our country the
American people have watched in horror
as left-wing extremists have looted
businesses violently assaulted innocent
civilians and brutally injured hundreds
and hundreds of police officers are
great police officers they even
vandalize that's right the Lincoln
Memorial the Lincoln Memorial
[Applause]
the radical lab thinks the future
belongs to them no the future belongs to
you it belongs to people that let's hope
not the people in there seemed to think
voting Trump's a good idea if the future
belongs to them were screwed so we're
not gonna take borrow lectures from the
same left-wing ideologues Hawks who
support deadly sanctuary cities who
wanted to fund our police to fund an
abolish our police right think of it the
fund it abolished is now their theme and
who preside over the violence and mayhem
of the 20 most dangerous cities in
America 24 20 20 most dangerous run by
Democrats cities in general tend to be
run by Democrats urban areas tend to be
more left-leaning it's a base rate
fallacy and you'd have to be pretty dumb
at this point to fall for it which is
perfect for this crowd Troy and
Baltimore is higher than that of El
Salvador Guatemala or Afghanistan but
the left branches and the case growth
rate of Arizona is higher than just
about any other country travesties
because it doesn't serve their radical
agenda think of the tougher than
Afghanistan all run by Democrats while
their movement is based on hate ours is
based on love love of our family love of
our nation and love of our fellow
citizens why
hums white-knuckling it huh
we embrace the noble vision of Reverend
Martin Luther King jr. and believe that
no no people should not be judged based
on the color of their skin no no but the
content of their care of what a
disgusting attacked
SiC this is a choice of two futures the
left's vision of disunity and discord or
our vision of equal opportunity and
equal justice every American should take
a long look at the bedlam in Seattle
because that's exactly what will come to
every city near you every suburb and
community in America if the radical left
Democrats are put in charge they want to
abolish I have any idea how ya know for
people asking in the chat whether the
policy part of the speech has happened
no there has been no such I mean I guess
immigrants are bad has been mentioned
fight I agree but you don't want to do
it look I'm looking at some pretty tough
guys right here look you're not gonna do
it
he's not going into a into an ms-13 nest
thanks for the membership you're number
20 these guys are tough they're smart
they're getting them out by the
thousands that take in ms-13 out of our
country by the thousands okay nobody
they want abolish ice get rid of ice
abolish bail they won Nobel anymore just
you know we put you in for murder it's
okay come back whenever you have a
chance you see what's going on in some
places like Philadelphia what's
happening in Philadelphia what's
happening in other cities look at what's
going on in Chicago what's that all
about Chicago is a great city but they
want to abolish borders and abolish
every Police Department in the country
the Democrats are also trying to rig
nobody wants to do that like 16% of
people want to do that it's never gonna
happen
Alice using the China virus
as the excuse for allowing people not to
go to the polls say we have a virus
coming we have to send think of it
California he's gonna be sending out
millions and millions of ballots
well where are they going where are
these ballots going who's getting them
registered voters who is not getting
them people who aren't registered a
little section this Republican will they
be stolen from mailboxes as they get put
in by the mailman pretty stupid there'd
be taken from the mailman and the mail
women
yes well somebody's going to essentially
robbed at gunpoint a male person four
ballots will they be counterfeited by
groups inside our nation no will they be
counterfeited maybe by the millions by
foreign powers no who don't want to see
Trump win because nobody has been
tougher on trade or making our country
great again nope nope not happen no mail
in ballots is a disaster for our country
it's gonna end up in a Bigfoot you know
look I'd love to see these conspiracies
combined like the fake news liberal
media will steal and counterfeit mail
ballots mailed ballots for example just
as an idea how are they delivered who's
not getting them think of it it's gonna
be fraud all over the place and if you
look right now if you look right now
look at all of the disputes are having
on mail-in ballots a friend of mine it
was a great guy had a son who passed
away seven years ago okay seven years
ago he came to see me the other day he
said they just sent to my son Robert a
mail-in ballot he died seven years ago
so he won't fill it in he won't send it
and there's no problem this is not
actually a problem
Ellen ballots you introduce something in
the middle of an election year and you
have something where it's very complex
you have no
thanks Kathleen to fix this very complex
number number 21 flex this will be in my
opinion the most corrupt election in the
history of our country oh I agree we
cannot let this happen they wanted to
happen so bad we believed in the sacred
principle of one person one vote and
that's why we are fighting for the
integrity of our elections wrong that's
alive absentee ballots are fine absentee
ballots are fine like I live in the
White House and if I can't get to
Florida or you mail in ballots means
people request absentee ballots that's
that's what we're talking about here get
to a polling station and they have good
reason but they have to go through this
process in order to judges widely have
found that fear of coronavirus is a good
reason to vote absentee they went to the
polls and voted during World War two we
can safely go to the polls we have
better technology now Kovan 19 I think
cheering today
and there's tremendous evidence of fraud
in others whenever you have mail-in
ballots wrong and frankly if we are
really going to protect your elections
and some people don't want to hear this
we must have voter ID here we go now
we're getting into the red meat dog
whistles
so as long as I'm president America will
see a land of fair laws swift justice
and Safe Communities and that's why when
rioting and looting broke out in our
nation's capital I quickly deplore I
came in I deployed the National Guard
very quickly mark Meadows was there with
a lot of our people there yeah we
stopped the violence we saved that
incredible statue you saw last night
yeah and restored peace and always Laura
for the ministry I will tell you they
did great damage to the cannons that
were on the ground they did great damage
but we'll get them fixed
we'll get them fixed lock him up
yeah lock them up it's incredible how
they can do it I'm credible where they
did damage we're lucky we just got there
in time you throw the ropes going up we
got there just and I'll tell you a law
enforcement did a great job they rushed
him right arrested
[Applause]
only mild clapping for that and these
people fought back and the law
enforcement was much tougher much
sharper much better they really had no
trouble handling him they put in the
handling a baby for them was just like a
baby
this Trump typically will be in that
group
it's weird spoiled lot of spoiled rich
people saying what are you doing here
weird to praise law enforcement for
handling protesters violently as if they
were babies that's odd
will face severe and lengthy criminal
penalties ten years many of the young
people here today have had your own
encounters with left-wing extremists
such as an tyfa joining us today are two
students from north carolina state
university great place great state they
claim to Jack Bishop please come on up
fellas Olive Oyl this should be a rare
treat by the way thank you to everybody
getting the memberships I do see it and
I'm so appreciative Judy Forman is
number 23 this should be special right
now see what we've got this is just
getting really awkward how are you guys
thanks oh my god listen thank you so
much mr. president it's great to be out
here in Phoenix I visit the first time
I've ever been here I've gotta say it's
been the experience of a lifetime
I'm not gonna say anything and let's not
make it this short and sweet
I just want to say that conservative
censorship on campus is real and it's
happening all across the country I'm not
gonna say anything this last year at NC
State we were having a event our
turning-point chapter was about Charlie
Burke and Laura Trump at her alma mater
NC State and we were posting ads
advertisements in our free expression
tunnel where you're allowed to paint
whatever you want
and we had about 20 socialist thugs roll
up from Antigua and from the young
democratic socialists of America now now
for our trouble of course they rolled up
and attacked us and they started
spraying all over the work that we had
just done and for my trouble of I stood
the line and tried my best oh my god to
confer to keep them from from defacing
our ads and for my trouble
I was spray painting in the eye oh my
god and unsurprisingly of course the
school did nothing there's a surprise
and they let aunt Eva run roughshod over
our event they let them in the in the
room with us they were protesting
screaming so loud that you could barely
hear the speakers the entire display
okay and of course like many
administrations across the country does
the will of the radical left
[Music]
meanwhile conservatives across the
country are punished and blacklisted
merely for expressing our own opinions
we're ostracized and ousted with no
support whatsoever from the
administration why are they both shaking
in this let me tell you when
administration's across the country do
the will of the left of the left and
cater to the mob it's our duty as
conservatives to stand up and to fight
for our rights and fight for our nation
and to fight for our guy and you know
mr. president I want to hear from mr.
president my dad congressman dan Bishop
he likes to say that you like to say
that he's not a son of a congressman
real meritocracy and let me tell you mr.
president
us college conservatives we ain't
chokers neither how old is this guy I
can't go with you 60 or 14 we're gonna
win this election we're gonna take back
the house we're gonna keep the Senate
and we're gonna get four more years of
the best presidents in my lifetime the
presidency of Donald J Trump Trump is in
a sense of the breast president that
seemed from the NDA's that seems clear
god bless you and God bless the United
States of America oh my goodness yeah
okay
mr. president thank you so much is an
honor to be here with you today thank
you for giving attention to our
situation when the mainstream media back
there wouldn't touched the story
conservatives across this country are
treated different every day by their
professors and other students on the
campus I was mocked by a leftist on my
campus not for my conservative beliefs
but for a medical condition I had that
impacts my hair growth and my ability to
sweat I'll learn that when these leftist
ideas fail they resort the personal
attacks because they have no facts to
back up their radical beliefs imagine
how much of a fit the mainstream media
would have thrown at 15 to 20 kids in
Maggi hats I'd come up and spray-painted
a kid in the eye and made some of
someone else for a medical condition
they have our school in North Carolina
state did not do anything about Trump
made fun of a guy for his medical
condition the hit the handicapped
reporter what do what do you mean
imagine
[Music]
we are blessed to have a president like
you that is devoted to protecting free
speech on college campuses and Thank You
president trove and students for Trump
let's keep America great something is
very very wrong here something is very
very wrong here
[Applause]
great job fellas thank you so you know I
signed an executive order as you know
yeah
and based on what I'm just hearing you
should maybe be talking to Charlie or
somebody around here about defunding
that school because that's exactly talk
to Charlie Cork about defunding an
entire school there you go we got the
executive order was based on so you
talked to the people maybe have your
father cause father's a great
congressman done a great job so say
hello to him but you talked to them
that's exactly what it was for we did
something that was radical but it wasn't
radical to me right not radical and I
heard if you can't be heard let's talk
about it okay as the radical left
inflict violence on American streets
they're also waging war on timeless
American values like freedom of speech
which is what we're just talking about
anyone who dares to speak the truth is
canceled
censored deep platformed fired expelled
harassed abused boycotted deprived of a
livelihood or even physically assaulted
those times will be changing first soon
I hope so you can judge a movement by
its behavior and the young Patriots here
today don't destroy property you don't
burn buildings you don't punish
dissenters and you don't try to erase
the people with whom you disagree
it's called civilized people you
civilize people okay
and yet remember I said this you're
civilized but you're much tougher right
and the others do much time you conduct
yourselves everybody's very tough and
Trump was just inspecting the bunker
that night the facts and the history all
on your side we're joined today by
Reagan escora a student at Northwestern
State last name again please the
University of Louisiana Reagan became a
target of liberal cancel culture when
she dared to stand up for a Christian
values instead of bowing to political
correctness Reagan please come up and
say a few words this is getting very
problematic guys thanks to Don Catherine
Benjamin and another Catherine for the
memberships up to 27 well thank you mr.
president for being here today with all
of us and for inviting me up here to
tell of my experience with canceled
culture council culture
my name is Reagan Eska day I graduated
from Northwestern State you know for
being the tough guys everybody's very
very much a victim have you noticed that
at a small private insurance company in
Louisiana a few weeks ago amidst all
this chaos that we're seeing with the
black lives matter movement I made a
video on my Instagram and I talked about
how disappointed I am in the church's
reaction to the black lives matter
movement I've seen pastors call for
white congregants to kneel and to
apologize
[Applause]
and to apologize for the skin that God
gave them and I and I addressed these
evangelical pastors and leaders and and
reminded them that racism is a problem
in the heart it is a sin problem that
cannot be resolved by any law protest or
March but why even do the civil rights
movement it's a problem in the heart I
mean we didn't even need 19 so we didn't
need brown be bored of educate we didn't
need any of it it's the heart guys and
so of course my leftist followers didn't
appreciate this message at all to spoil
them I had my name blasted all over
social media and people told me you know
I'm ashamed to have ever called you my
friend I've lost all respect for you I
love y'all and so an ex-coworker of the
guys this is a presidential rally racist
and homophobic and she listed my place
of employment and called for people to
call my employer and have me fired
isn't that speech there were death
threats made to the owners that's not
open there were threats to knock down
the building law enforcement had to get
involved and due to the crazy reaction
from the leftist mob my employer told me
that they came to the conclusion that
they needed to terminate my employment
but here's the thing here's the thing
losing my job is a small price to pay
when God's name is being glorified and
he will always make his name known is
everyone in there super religious or are
they just kind of going with the crowd I
share this story with you because what
happened to me is is just a small
example of something that's happening on
a much larger scale in our nation yeah a
lot of people on social media who
shouldn't be was canceled and if you
didn't know Nancy green the original
first aunt jemima she was a picture of
the American dream she was a freed slave
who went on to be the face of the
pancake syrup that we love and have in
our pantries today yeah she fought for
equality the foremost civil rights issue
of our time we really like on Jemima
syrup and might I mentioned how
privileged we are as a nation if our
biggest concern is a bottle of pancake
syrup well it's not the biggest concern
great job we more recently we're seeing
a call for statues of Jesus Christ to be
torn down if they're on government
property they should be because it's an
establishment of one religion over
others well justice warrior and this
week he's the face of white supremacy
and Jimmy Kimmel has been calling our
president racist for years and it turns
out he's the racist racism
there's there's governors that are
getting away with wearing blackface
that's just sliding under the radar so I
want to encourage you all to stand firm
in your beliefs we need truth we need
hard cold facts and truth now more than
we ever have before and we are so
blessed to have a president who stands
on the frontlines walks through the fire
every day guys they think Trump was sent
by God they think Trump was sent by God
[Applause]
Trump can barely walk down a ramp and
drink water they think he was sent by
God
do not apologize to the mob and Thank
You President Trump for never
apologizing to the mob for always
standing firm for being here for the
American people and for fighting for our
best interests because you are the
change that we need to see in America
thank you okay
while disgusting absolutely disgusting
thank you Reagan we've got a rap uniform
you know as your story reminds us Reagan
true courage is defying the left's
Orthodox as your story reminds us I
shouldn't be here
picking who gets to speak because we're
winning and we're going to win but you
don't submit the fake news progressive
companies right there they're right back
there watching us right back there and
other institutions merely toeing the
left-wing line have sacrificed their
intellectual credibility and a
professional integrity they have very
little integrity left when I talk of
intellectual credibility I think of
Trump and Stephen Miller and those guys
be showing real guts and making a
virtuous stand with the rise of social
media massive multinational tech
companies have tried to clamp down on
American democracy that even means on me
right and as everyone knows they're
using their enormous power to silence
conservative voices you know that it's
not even close I don't even think
they're hiding it anymore
to protect our democracy I signed an
executive order to remove legal
protections for social media companies
that unjustly censor American citizens
which interpreted properly means Twitter
must ban Trump but that's a story for
another day the radical left is also
working to eliminate free speech on our
college campuses with us today is near
more a student at the University of st.
Thomas in Minnesota uh-oh whose
experiences persecution firsthand dear
please come up please more carefully
chosen pops
[Applause]
first I just want to say thank you to
mr. president for having me on stage
today okay
[Applause]
so if you didn't know much about
Minnesota about a month ago I'm sure
you've seen us in the headlines over the
past few weeks the DFL is successfully
moving our state further to the left
more and more each day now that isn't
because people aren't conservative in
Minnesota it's because they're hell-bent
on demonizing us at every turn I began
my career working in politics with
turning-point USA bad idea
worst mistake unfortunately due to the
leftist culture of my campus at North
Hennepin we were shut down almost
immediately and were refused official
recognition
I was told by the faculty that political
groups were not welcome on campus
however they had multiple leftist groups
that supported but the black lives
matter movement
they were pro-abortion and they've
advocated for Bernie Sanders our Gus is
one of those things where it's like who
knows how much of this story is even
true it's like there are these out of
context anecdotes whose veracity we
can't even really know in the moment and
and it's it's all just optics and
propaganda for the purposes of this
rally Republicans and the president take
the blame for what has taken place
unfortunately the murder of George Floyd
has created absolute chaos in my state
of Minnesota it's created past more than
just from that sense
[Applause]
ever since the murder of George Floyd I
have not seen as much division deceit
and destruction in my life
black lives matter only makes the scene
during election years that was worded
strangely it almost sound like she was
saying things have improved it that was
weird
important election of our time
[Applause]
black lives matter is only about police
brutality once every four years in
between they're heavily funding a push
for leftist and lgbtq+ agendas yeah the
black communities college agendas like
non-discrimination and and and being
treated fairly hidden agendas and play
on the community's biggest fear this is
bad like really bad if black lives
matter truly cared about black lives
they would not have allowed the riots to
destroy black businesses and black
communities yeah overwhelmingly peaceful
obviously as we know protesters
protesting with some bad actors that
seek to take advantage of the situation
they cared about black lives they would
defund Planned Parenthood if black lives
matter cared about black lives they
would adjust the astronomically high
numbers of black on black crime in
inner-city right remember that that's
that's a ruse if you're black and you're
the victim of a crime the perpetrator
was probably black if you're white and
you're the victim of a crime by almost
the exact numbers the perpetrator of
that crime was white because there's a
lot of people just around people that
are like them and that is I mean I can't
even believe they're still using that
one we do believe black lives matter
we just believe they all matter not just
the lives the left chooses to exploit I
would love a mention of the war on drugs
at some point maybe I am the field
director for Ilhan Omar's Challenger
lacy Johnson
here's the first republican in minnesota
to have black lives matter activists and
lifelong democrats want to hear what he
has to say because of that they've tried
to silence us at every turn people are
fed up and they're getting nervous very
nervous there I would rap at nothing to
keep art there hold on us even if that
means lying to the very people they're
supposed to represent mr. president I
just want to say thank you for being an
exact great example of a big tent
Republican I would cut the president has
never needed the black vote to win but
he's still done incredible work with
prison reform he'll be lucky to get
black unemployment funding HBCUs and
stimulating the black community but the
opportunity's own in conclusion please
vote I'm always out pandering
did you guys hear that last part
oh the president asked the black
community what we had to lose right
alone have anything but now we do Thank
You mr. president
dear God
what a sad state of affairs thank you
took the combination of gas lighting red
meat and lies I don't even know just
tell you first of all thank you very
much and so heartfelt I could see that
and I also issued a historical executive
order a store pending free speech and
nice doses or in college campuses and I
will tell you that it's something that's
being used by people like Charlie and
used very well and it's opening up a
whole new voice then it's my honor to
have done it under my order any college
that refuses to let you speak stands to
lose billions of dollars in terms of the
overall body cancer
so we've done a lot we've really gone
very far we've taken it to a level that
nobody has ever taken it and it's my
honor to have done it it's people like
you that I do it for when you think
about it it's people like you you're
going to be the ones you're going to be
the ones that are at the crossroads of
history that's where you are right now
you're at a crossroads everything our
forefathers built everything generations
passed they shed their blood to defend
the very survival of our freedoms our
rights in our republic they're all at
stake this is a very big time in our
country right it's a time like perhaps
no other but standing here before you
today I have never been more confident
that America will rise to new heights of
greatness and glory
hopefully by realizing they got to vote
for somebody else thanks to this speech
sir filled with the fire and the fervor
of true American patriots
[Applause]
the great spirit of righteous defiance
stirs deep within us either it's the
same spirit that drove America's fry
wanders round frontiersmen people that
built our nation grounders people that
succeeded people that worked hard people
that failed people that failed some
people failed and then they made it
bigger than anyone seems to be really
leaning on that I mean he doesn't look
well he's leaning on the podium he's
very very sweaty as you can tell it's
something seems wrong sit establish this
noble Fortress of freedom it's the same
spirit that compels each of you to stand
strong against the dull mindless
soul-crushing conformity mandated by far
left pundits professors and liberal
politicians on they're taking our
country in the wrong direction and it's
the same fierce and untamed American
spirit that will lead the young
patriotic Americans of this generation
to serve our country and you will serve
it well you will serve it so well he
does seem to be coming down now yeah
restore our economy quickly we will
rebuild our nation we will revitalize
our cities we will take back our
universities and colleges and we will
preserve the America we love for you and
for your children we will defend our
values our voices our faith our heritage
our borders our rights and our god-given
freedoms
[Music]
calling on the boldness and bravery of
your generation we will unite citizens
of every race and color religion and
Creed as one people one family and one
extraordinary nation under God maybe by
voting into the house but I thought I
wouldn't see
and with your help this moment will be a
turning point in American history that
will be remembered and celebrated for
generations to come
I hope so for our young people for our
economy for our communities and for our
beloved country the best is yet to come
thank you god bless you
once we got yes
[Applause]
oh my goodness if we were wondering how
weaponized and unhinged this would be we
probably underestimated we probably
underestimated absolutely stunning
combination of lies propaganda
disinformation sweating name dropping
what am I missing here I mean this is
just you know if the best is coming it's
got to be under somebody else I don't
know there's Charlie Kirk and Don Jr who
Trump seems to recognize at least as a
son wow wow wow wow what an incredible
incredible day I don't know how much of
it is based on over-the-counter
decongestants I don't know how much of
it is based on cognitive circumstances
or or whatever else but just absolutely
incredible and we're gonna have a lot of
analysis of it tomorrow I do want to say
thanks to so many people who signed up a
James was new member number 28 at join
pakman.com Alexis volcán was number 29
Richard Schaffer was number 30 I mean
these membership numbers are numbers
we've never seen before
rajendra Bala was number 31
Elizabeth missile was number 32
super-duper missile as trump said don
magner it's number 30 i can't even thank
everybody because people have been just
exploding it's absolutely unbelievable
what an event what an event before you
head out if you are watching on youtube
please hit the subscribe button we do
stream these events occasionally we also
post videos I'm David by the way if you
just stumbled across this please do hit
that subscribe button if you're heading
out but I've got a couple other things
to show you if you're watching on Twitch
make sure to follow we did just surpass
thirty seven thousand followers on
Twitch and we're actually at six hundred
and sixty-six twitch subscribers which
seems like an ominous number if you care
about that sort of thing so that's just
a little something to bear in mind folks
asked me to play a couple of the cameos
that I've been doing I am on cameo now
and this may have been a huge mistake
I'm on cameo at cameo dot-com slash
david pack
or just David Pakman in the app just
like as an example I'll play one of
these here's here's a cameo that I did
and anybody can can get these done let's
take a listen to just one of them hey
Matt so I heard from KC that you spent
$600 on an online charisma class now
maybe you're very wealthy and if that's
the case that's fine but in my
experience you can find a lot of that
material for free and I would even be
glad for you to call into my show when
I'm taking live calls and talk about
what I'm told is maybe a desire to
improve some dating skills okay so
anyway I'll just pick one other random
one I'll pick one from today let's see
this one's also marked advice let's take
a look I don't even know what I'm saying
in half of these so I heard that you may
be falling into being one of these
so-called enlightened centrists who
thinks maybe all opinion alright we're
not gonna do more anyway you guys you
sort of get the idea of what's going on
there thank you to everybody who joined
me that's gonna do it for today we've
got more clips coming I might stream
tomorrow then we've got a little
vacation coming up and so much more is
happening I mean it's gonna be a crazy
four and a half months until the
election I will be here with you and I
look forward to seeing you on the next
one
you